welcome to no episode of not too deep
it's a very exciting episode we have
candy Johnson back with us it's her
second time on the podcast she's a mom a
mogul a master of the flashback Friday
throwback Thursday photos and just an
infinite well of wisdom and joy and I
could honestly listen to this woman talk
about anything forever so I hope that
you are infected by how precious this
soul is enjoy this episode of not too
deep with candy Johnson hey you
you got a great idea that you're ready
to turn into a reality I have the
companion for you it's Squarespace they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project if you want to showcase
your work or if you want to sell a
product of any kind they've beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything so you can easily
make a beautiful website all by yourself
but if you get stuck they have 24/7
award-winning customer support that is
there to help you out so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain candy Johnson is back on not too
deep I'm so excited that you're here
me too oh my god okay so we talked a
little bit we've had to reschedule this
multiple times no no no no I wanted you
because you're the most joyous spirit
and so on that I've never encountered
but we've had two cats on our and
multiple times but the first time was
you had to deal with the actual fire
sale yeah yeah that was my fault no it
was but like I think it's populated from
house yeah I think it was like nature's
fault at that point which is so insane
but everything's okay yeah I just
would've been like candy in three days
of the same sweatpants but I left my
house and I'm your podcast I mean I love
technically what I'm wearing right now
it's like the same clothes that I've
been wearing for three days but that was
insane like that was a real and you were
I thought a little bit on your Instagram
story it was like flames like I by the
end of the street and I was driving out
like my house is a goner like oh well
but that's crazy and also like how do
you manage in that moment how much
you're like posting online about like
with the reality of everything that's
happening to you versus like I don't
know how to process this myself right
now it's weird because like when you do
things on the internet I come you you're
like oh this is crazy I did share this
so it's not me alone Frank and we were
stuck in like traffic we couldn't leave
the neighborhood like we were just stuck
cuz like hundreds of thousands of cars
are trying to all go to the freeway we
were stuck there I was like I guess I'll
film these flames this is a real thing
that's happening it's crazy because then
later when I'm in my hotel room that we
evacuated to I played back didn't really
realize when I was just sitting there
and I was like Oh Instagram stories
maybe there's a little real no I was
watching it being like holy [ __ ] like
yes I was on the opposite side of Los
Angeles so I didn't really have to like
deal with it first yeah it was very real
it was more real estate on your
Instagram story than it was seeing on
any like yeah real cuz I was like that's
on my street and there were flames like
up behind my house that part didn't film
because I was like we're gonna catch on
fire this looks like I'm literally in
hell like but so you guys were evacuated
you went to a hotel and then you
basically just sit at the hotel until
they tell you until a person tells you
that you can go back yeah well you check
like you would keep checking and seeing
if you could go back and then and then
like so many people evacuated there
weren't hotels for continuous nights so
it was like we're sold out for tomorrow
already so it was like so you do in the
hotel wake up search call 25,000 hotel
see who had it I was driving all over
like Warren County up like another 60
miles somewhere else it was so insane
they in the same sweat pants
I left my butt's so no it's trying to
upload videos in the lobby looking like
a crazy person
creating your content still trying to
upload it like a little Wi-Fi okay this
is why you will never fail at anything
you do it because you are a consummate
businesswoman through and through even
though your entire at home you were
saying you're like I've never prepared
for a fire but the things I grabbed
leaving my house or like hard drive like
computers I'm like I can't replace you
you can rebuild my house yeah you uh
unintentionally Marie Kondo to your
house yeah Marie Kondo all the joy is
gone that's nuts
okay but let's talk about your work
ethic is like Bar nuns I feel like well
I feel like there's a lot of content
creators because what you started in
what 2008 yeah I think I filmed my first
video in 2008 and then I did upload it
till January 2009 I was like I don't
know but still that's extremely early on
the platform yeah there was like so few
people it was great you are gonna be a
star cuz there's only ten people to
watch how did you hear about YouTube
when you first felt like what how did
you find you yeah cuz like who was
watching YouTube like nobody I found it
because my I had an editing teacher in
my I took an editing class in college
and my teacher made us all sign up for
YouTube so we could share our progress
each other I thought it was an
intercollegiate like website I just
shared your work yeah I didn't realize
that it was like a global platform until
later and so now there's videos from
2007 that aren't my editing like
projects from college that are still
much love it but how did you find
YouTube resilient my friend showed me
this girl Lauren Luke her name is
panacea 81 Wow and she was Janice
panacea 81 huh and she's like the whole
reason I started because she was doing
makeup tutorials and she was just
showing how you use these palettes in
London and somewhere in around London UK
and her dog would be snoring in the
background it should be dropped I was
like she's so cute I just embryos
and I was like what I've been to makeup
artist for years I could teach all the
women they were like I never learned how
and I was like this is genius yeah and
then I don't know I was i I think I just
really you don't even see my face in the
first video I had a cold it doesn't even
sound like me no one would even know
it's me you don't see my face and then
people were like so excited and they're
like oh tell me this tell me this he'll
do this how do you what do you eat how
do you call your shirt how do you do I
was like I was like cranking out like
sometimes three videos a day every day I
was like a gamer this is how you do your
eyebrows this is it was like wow I look
back now I'm like what the heck but what
was I doing there was no pressure of
course video quality was poor but it was
even poorer but I feel like you started
back then it's just you you're doing
everything and I didn't make money at it
it was like purely for the love all
right like the joy of being able to like
not be told you couldn't put something
on a and there was no it was like the
Wild West there was nothing like my
thumbnails were so terrible I didn't
even know about thumbnails so 2010 I
know you could make them I was like I'll
guess you to pick that for me I'll take
this derp face then there's a blinking
and it's pretty dark and shady but they
feel like you still retain like you grow
in your business you've grown your brand
you've grown like all of your content
creation but you're still do it like you
can still tell it's from you like you
don't know so yeah that's the thing that
I respect so much is that a lot of
people you know bill at these big
production teams and then you're like oh
it's so glassy that's what I mean it
makes just glassy content that feels a
little like less personal like your
friend doesn't feel like your friend
with the dog snoring in the UK anymore
exact doesn't feel like oh you had an
idea at 3:00 a.m. and you can't sleep so
you're making it
anyway yeah I think you still retain
that which i think is so cool
thank you do you ever cuz I constantly
kind of juggle with the idea of like I
want to make sure I'm still staying true
to myself and doing the stuff that I
like doing when I first started for sure
then also like should I have a bigger
team helping me like how do you men
manage all that I think that's like been
the number one thing that I've struggled
with is because and I think I probably
and like not controlling in life like
I'm not like going to dinner like my
creativity like what I worked on I feel
like I'm very it's like your baby you
know so like even editing I've had very
few videos edited by other people really
and I somebody edits better than me I
know it oh yeah but and I should let go
of that and then even bringing people in
I think it's really hard unless you know
they're equal if not better than what
you're doing it's really hard to let go
of control and I could just do it faster
you know if I get do it myself which
isn't good but I'll yeah it isn't go
because then you give yourself that much
more work denied anything till like 5:00
in the morning or 7:00 I'm not sleeping
in the next day I'm like I hate the
pendulum swings hard yeah but I mean you
balance a full life outside of just
making like beauty videos like it's
insane how much you manage like which I
agree yeah what's your day-to-day like
on a normal basis I mean the day today
is hard because like no matter how I
stay up late editing I still have to get
up and take my kids to school and this
doesn't start at 10:00 you know it's
right so then that's hard to be in that
mode and then I usually have to come
back and then it's like meetings or a
lot of timelines and deadlines for other
projects I'm working on that aren't
YouTube based and YouTube I just I'm I'm
going to film my next video in the next
couple days it's terrible this is a
longest break I've taken from YouTube
like really how long has it been since
December like there's been no video at
2019 okay Bailey I mean I get your
anxiety again
the fact that like every month feels
like a year toy your YouTube like time
moves in the different we like speed
speed on YouTube and online and you feel
like you might be forgotten or you feel
like you might be like I'm scared that
algorithm I'm scared of jumping back
into battle rhythm is gonna show my
video to two people this is great yeah
I've given up on trying to figure that
out it takes a hieroglyphic that I will
never actually understand not real we're
not showing it algorithm I know
Shane Dawson will do a conspiracy theory
about what's going on there yet you have
three kids or four kids yeah okay we
stay here too long
okay wait how old are what are the ages
8 11 13 and 22 Wow yeah I just whatever
age it rains you want demographic I got
how do you do you have any presets on
them of like if they want to make videos
like is there anything that you're like
I don't want you guys to be on YouTube
or like you can do whatever you want I
mean it's weird because they grew up
with it like my little one was I was
literally a little girl that is your
mini-me is the sweetest little peach
I've ever seen so sweet videos oh my
gosh she just melts me she sounds like a
cartoon character she's the cutest thing
I've ever seen oh yeah she's she's grown
up with it so it's so funny like I was
literally editing like two hours after I
gave birth to her like she literally
probably has like weird electromagnetic
radiation made you okay
like right like some people go to
offices and they're not physically
present your present so this year fully
understand oh yeah she loves it like she
loves it and then the kids they'd you
too really wasn't popular my first few
years there right you know we're making
a video long and then now they're like
oh my gosh you know so and so so I was
coming over like now they're just like
really in it and they think it's so
crazy and they I mean they've grown up
with this okay like I mean they have
better advice like I like what's popular
with my son he's like mom you gotta stop
doing those favorites videos because no
one wants to see monthly favorites
anymore I was like wow he's like you
need to do some challenges he's like
kids watch Alan they're not he's like
nobody cares all your favorite products
are high key just builds it all out oh
my god you should just start like having
them just become advisors my creative
content my calendar look like guys like
well you got challenges you're making
every kind of slime in the world I was
gonna ask what is the thing that you cuz
slime to me is like such a joke right
now I know like is it still going
I don't think done is it dead I don't
know I live in a new crop of
three-year-olds it like slime I feel
like it's gonna come in waves
Elmer's glue is just like paying people
in videos there's more money honestly
that might be what's happening and then
whatever ingredients are in it yeah I
was gonna say how do you maintain like
your content is it I feel like it feels
so random being and it's weird because I
don't like I don't like being labeled or
limited to a later or like even when
people ask what you do it's really weird
like on planes I just dread that
question people like what do you do I'm
like oh my gosh here we go yeah well
that's how I've been starting off this
podcast with what's your deal
everyone is very taken aback and like
uncomfortable with that but I'm the same
thing with you that like when someone
says like what do you do on a plane when
somebody's like what do you do what do
you lead off with I say I think I say if
I I think I say comedy I do comedy and
then when they say like it's cool but it
right but then they go oh are you a
stand-up and I go no and then I wait so
where do you do comedy and then I say oh
I do make youtube videos primarily and
then do they look like that's where the
weird look comes in anyway and then it's
just it's almost inviting more question
becomes a full-blown question I should
do a bank I don't know I work at forever
21 I'm a college dropout I have nothing
to offer you in this conversation this
is me politely declining to engage with
you I've gotten so anxious about editing
on planes that usually just complains
all the time you'd be totally fine and
like headphones in think that I'm in
like to meet you and then one time a guy
just like poked me with my headphones
lands and I had to take them off and
he's like what are you doing video and
it like he totally broke the social wall
I know it's like do you not understand
hola yes actually
and so now that's like ruined me to edit
on planes anymore that I'm like PTSD
about that interaction that I'm like I'm
too embarrassed to edit this video cuz
it's your face who's watching their own
face they're like either think you're a
narcissist or like what and then they'll
be the same thing headphones they're
like is that you but but you still edit
all of your videos yeah the motion
probably stopped because I'm not really
good at it I think I'm better at that
than I am I'm like normal make more
videos like me you're like they're
pretty terrible I know I haven't
since college any classes on editing and
I'm the same way that I'm like classes
though basically just a class that
taught me how Final Cut works and then
you were already ahead of the game but
then I don't have final cut final couple
i we have Final Cut Pro X now but I had
like the whatever College version of it
was so it was it taught me enough to
know how to make jump cuts basic that's
amazing I was googling Windows Movie
Maker in 2008 I was like oh my god is a
Dell laptop even get iMovie it but I
think that's where the charm still is
that's what I'm afraid sometimes to give
my videos to an editor because I feel
like people will know I didn't do it
yeah that it's yeah that it's actually
like there isn't just 20 seconds of
black space that I forgot about in the
middle of it and that's what makes it my
own power music selection because I
don't have like someone writing me song
yeah that's three royalty-free loops
that I use on every single five times I
got to pick a new old town country road
old country years I remember memory and
I watched Colleen ballinger like
announcing that she's pregnant video and
the first thing both of us said was like
oh she used life of Riley and the track
I can't you said any more people are
gonna so she ate that with her pregnancy
announcement video that's literally the
first thing we both said out loud to
each other we're like alright yep that's
her theme song now yeah exactly
well know there was like a royalty song
it's in iTunes yeah and good mythical
morning use it like years ago and I use
no one use you stole good mythical
morning steam song like it's like one of
35 songs that you can use and I mean me
okay I don't know what it's called but
that's all I got like it's yeah we're
limited folks okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back I have a
lot of questions for you about just how
the beauty industry has a little too
deep
[Music]
two deep would you look at that it's
time for you to turn your dream into a
reality with Squarespace who happens to
be supporting this episode of not too
deep Squarespace makes it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
let's say you want to start a new
business
would you like to showcase your work
would you like to publish your content
would you like to sell products or more
well Squarespace is the tool for you
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself plus
they have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and they have analytics
that help you grow your site in real
time plus everything is optimized for
mobile right out of the box because we
all use our phones more than computers
most of the time and they got you
covered there's nothing to patch or
upgrade ever and buying domains is
simple you can get all the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support if you need it they
empower millions of people from
designers to lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms and now you to help you
turn your great ideas into something
real so head to squarespace.com slash
Grace for a free trial when you're ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace to support
for today's episode comes from
bareMinerals the creators of clean
beauty purity and formulation and
uncompromising performance have always
been the guiding principles of Bare
Minerals because they believe that
makeup and skin care should make your
skin better not just better looking and
this has been the bareMinerals
philosophy since they began the clean
beauty revolution in 1995 some of you
probably weren't even born in 1995 but
they were making money moves in 1995
with their best-selling original
foundation which offers creamy
lightweight buildable coverage that's
naturally luminous and the clean formula
is made with only 5 good for skin
ingredients you guessed it they're all
minerals including non-chemical SPF
protection makeup soap
you're you can sleep in it I mean don't
do that but you could and it actually
improves your skin over time it's
everything your skin needs nothing it
doesn't because for bareMinerals to be
clean without compromise means good for
skin formulas with proven performance
and like every bare minerals product
it's 100% cruelty free and better yet
both the original and that loose powder
foundations are available in 30 shades
so upgrade to clean beauty products use
the foundation finder at bare minerals
calm to find your perfect match first
time customers will get 15% off when you
use the promo code not too deep that's
bare minerals calm promo code not too
deep for 15% off your first purchase
bare minerals the power of good candy
Johnson okay so you've been in the
beauty industry on YouTube forever wait
like the grandma yeah I'm like the dr.
Dre you start like you have like all the
certifications you have every like a
professional makeup artist for like 10
years before which I'm a I imagine that
when you in the beauty industry on
YouTube really started to take off if
that was a hard thing to be like Oh
lumped into this kind of you know
stereotype that it's just a bunch of
like little girls like putting like
makeup yeah that you how to do their own
makeup but door ahead and do other
people's makeup and you should be like
no no I actually kind of yeah like I
really can't do it on other face shapes
and I doesn't work on everybody's eyelid
just saying yeah have you had like
combat that over the years yeah I think
so because people be like oh this is how
you're supposed to do it and I was like
how you're supposed to do it if you're
one girl that learned how to do it
herself you don't know what that looks
like in real life because you can filter
up a video and Instagram uh-huh and so
that's we're just seeing things done
really wrong like yeah heck that's gonna
give you eye infection or yeah are there
people that you watch that you think are
doing it right as well I really like
glam and gore oh yeah she's my eating
yeah yeah she seems a lot like you and
the fact that she's like professionally
trained and like special effects knows
how to do all that kind of stuff I think
she went to school to fill
school or something - for editing or
something I could be made not up but I
think so I'm sure but like people like
that that really have a passion for like
she has a passion for the special
effects yeah other people that have the
passion for their area mm-hmm they just
they go in depth when they share
knowledge it's coming from their place
of passion
yeah all right that I think is different
if you watch it you feel that yeah you
also worked on glam masters oh yeah okay
that was a bun yeah talk about this this
was a reality competition show yeah
with it on it was on lifetime and Kim
Kardashian was executive producer so
that was you know like a big so Mario
her makeup artist he was one of the
judges and it was so fun for so many
reasons I mean we were doing like
18-hour days some days but it's a beauty
competition show yeah and so their
challenges would take like forever and
then they'd have a photograph on with
all these different like 360 cameras and
you'd be like it's 3:00 in the morning
just hurry up but it was amazing because
one I didn't have to edit a thing
they're like a princess or something I
think I just have to get my hair done
him and make it done like that I felt
like I was Kim Kardashian Oh like I am
living my best life yeah don't worry I'm
like I don't have to get thumbnails I
don't have to get still shot I don't
have to promote this am it that's what
having a team around you it was great
did what was your initial reaction when
they came to you to do this show were
you like all on board immediately or
they had come to me like two years
earlier it was like a long working
process or a long time finding the host
finding the other people everything but
I was always like on board to do it and
I couldn't done that all day long people
like oh my gosh we were here 18 hours
like we sat in a chair terrible job in
my life for 18 hours that would have
been held like this is a dream folks you
gotta go
terrible job now that perspective is so
healthy and so grounding and like
cleaning anybody's toilets I'm like
heaven yeah they make us food and snacks
it ya know that's so important to have
that kind of perspective and mamrie is
really great at that when we're on set
and if any of us are grumpy she just
literally goes we could be digging
ditches and then we go oh we're so yay
to be able to do this [ __ ] right now
and this is what you're getting paid for
like yeah those moments hit me all the
time and I'm like remember when you're
at you're waitressing job and you just
be like daydreaming of anything else the
reason you could quit how you could yeah
I'll sell shoes on eBay anything just to
not be here tomorrow how was it being a
judge folks I feel like that I get too
nervous about telling people all the
criticisms make me be the pallav you
made me be Simon but it was great
because we had like such a big cast and
like they were better at dishing out
this stuff and sometimes I mean just
from a place of care I was like right I
mean this is you can't you can't be
crazy like cheering everybody yeah you
know on call spade a spade
when something's bad it's only gonna
make them better people is that how you
originally met Kim Kardashian no I met
her before I think I actually met Kris
Jenner and Kylie Jenner and an event I
did this like a nail polish thing for
the same line she did like I felt like
that was such a big step down there like
we're doing a collection with Kylie
Jenner and then next I just felt like I
was like are you sure
oh this is like a rule floor for my
level from Kylie but I met them and Kris
Jenner is amazing like she is so kind
and wonderful and nice and I feel like
you see people portrayed on a reality
show in some way and you don't see how
amazing their heart is like I'm watching
dealing with all of these kids issues on
the phone getting Kylie there she's on
the phone about one other child's event
or something and then and then her just
being charming and sweet and nice to
people I was like that's crazy
are you like this fairy person yeah and
then I met um Kim a couple times she had
like a thing at her house like a beauty
launch for her event and then and then I
don't know we met I met like at a
birthday party at Kylie's birthday party
something like that but then we only
like filmed a video together right you
did the Jasmine transformation with her
yeah yeah which is crazy because
normally those take me like four hours
and I like um Kim has 45 minutes for
weight really up costume and wig and I
was like hours yes it was like the
fastest makeup job so I watching I'm
like oh my gosh trash you want a Streamy
for it I don't know how I was like so
embarrassed three me are you days on
those eyebrows like girl we on I guess
somehow wanna stream me so wait you got
hate on the eyebrows first people were
hating on Kim you know and I was like
all people are mean yeah and then they
start hating on me and I like hey okay
you were already mean to her and I was
about there they were like our eyebrows
you messed up I was like you guys I'm
not trying to give her Kim Kim's daily
eyebrows right and give her the cartoon
like look at them nothing for a furnace
tree I'm trying to jazz it up folks and
there it is like everyone will find a
problem with everything and you know I
couldn't see the one side of her face at
45 minutes I was freaking out I wasn't
walking to that side I did not blend on
the one side like don't kill me I know
how to blend you have my other videos
but the two thousand other videos on her
face look good you just couldn't see it
come on stand in front of it where I
could see okay now you've come out with
makeup lines it seems like based on some
vague tweets you got some stuff in the
word that's amazing
works how do you go about because I feel
like I don't
very minimal about makeup but I feel
like there's a lot of scrutiny on like
the kind of product to you and yeah how
do you even go about starting to develop
like a makeup line or a pallet or things
like that I mean I think those things
are so hard I just did the collaboration
with Too Faced so it was easy because
they have like they're like a machine
you know I would just be like these are
all my colors and reworked I was just
annoying about the shades and like the
texture and the cell but then I think
that's purposeful I don't think that's
annoying
yes I'm glad they didn't hate me I was
like oh my gosh and then we finally got
the palettes back I was like this black
eye shadow is not black enough really
and that they were like it was I was
like no I don't like we can't and do
this and didn't cost them like like six
figure numbers to take this color out
and have it remade and I felt terrible
but also you have to stand by your butt
the first time my name will be on a
palette and they were so great they're
like we're gonna do it and I was like oh
thank you but no you would have been
kicking yourself I dunno if I'd have
been like oh this just let it go I'm
like it needs to be like I want like the
darkest black eyeshadow around and
somehow it wasn't and I was like that's
a sign of a great collaborator to
someone that actually like listens to
what you say and like it just really
working there yeah everything so I feel
like nowadays I feel like it's really
hard and I feel like everybody's got a
makeup line now like yeah I mean I was a
kid at 12 years old in like the 90s you
know I'd be mixing I'd be chucking up
like my Bonnie Belle you know lip smack
and lip balms and I'd be like scraping
out different eyeshadows and mixing of
making lip washes a little mad makeup
scientist like I wanted to do a makeup
line since since the 90s yeah then and
so I feel like now everybody's got to
make up mine like every person is
Instagram YouTube they all have a line
so it's like a turd me from wanting to
do it because I really like now it's
oversaturated not so much but I know my
stuff would be like nothing anybody has
but that's not gonna look like anybody
so that's what I mean I feel like your
stuff has been
literally years years years years years
decades in the making and your brand
that it's like whatever you create I
trust the product because well I already
your palette I use every day still
really yeah the white that one's gone
probably that's gone that and the yellow
are gone out of my sister's yeah can you
just make more of this and like I can't
just smell everything smells amazing so
like it's gotta smell like vanilla no
it's great I love every single shade
there but the eye
I trust because you are an expert and
you actually are super thoughtful and
caring about like the things that you
create that I would trust anything you
make so I can imagine that it must be a
difficult process to get exactly what
you want you want like my history of
duty I mean I've done this for years
I've makeup indoors outdoors on set you
know in the wilderness on every type of
you know every age like so I feel like I
have so many requirements of things like
it's got to do XY and Z it can't be some
20 year old it's like oh I I smear
Vaseline with a tinted and is glorious
like that doesn't work yeah and when
you're beyond 20 you know so what is the
what do you see are the next trends
makeup-wise they feel like this what I
when I see and what I want are probably
two different what do you want to be the
next sentence cuz I feel like
highlighters been a thing that when I
was when I was growing up highlighter I
had never knew existed until like five
years ago they made it like there wasn't
highlighters really it was just like you
put blush on mm-hmm that's all your
cheek Scott was gonna blush exactly I
and I also stay away from highlighter
because I just naturally under like
lighting start to sweat anyway but I'm
like now I just look like I'm in an oily
face exactly yeah what do you hope is a
trend that comes up I hope a return to a
more simple natural beauty like oh it's
just beautiful skin making your skin
beautiful and less of so much I mean
there's so many young girls you see 13
14 15 girls with so much eye makeup so
much stuff so much everywhere I'm like
you look like your 3812
you know yeah and I feel like it's fun I
love makeup but I love playing with it
and I love everybody practicing and
playing but I think everybody's just
latched on to this one look of so much
makeup with a cut crease
all this stuff and yeah you don't see
that every day I don't go to the grocery
store and I'm like wow look at that cut
crease with 25 shades that bread aisle
is like you know like unless I go to
makeup events I'm like just they're
shoving off everywhere yeah but Oh
day-to-day I mean I'm with you I feel
like I'd like you reached that age when
you start to like you can wear makeup
and so you play with it and you go
overboard and then hopefully you start
to scale back a little bit yeah I want
to look pretty I don't want to look I
don't want people to be like all your
makeup is amazing I'm like what there's
a face under here although you're the
master of the throwback Thursday
flashback Friday photo yes when I've got
like nothing left to do am i got no good
picture this we were no photos of you as
a teenager are so Moody and so wonderful
and I just saw the photo that you post
of you and your sister wearing like
Levi's like it's like 501 my dad my
pants are so amazing and the fact that
you have all those photos - I mean
that's maybe all I have coz who took
pictures back then like nobody was
taking pictures true true yeah there's a
national camera and I'm not not at a out
of school of function photo nobody's
taking things they just live in their
lives do you need to get permission from
your sister when you post those no
headgear moment bo and I won headgear
and I was like how do you feel about
this one on the Internet
and she's like oh you don't approve of
the freshly applied headgear I love it
they always look like an old like my
so-called life campaign oh it's amazing
it kills me every week I can't see what
else you
I've got one fan and grace thing oh no
but also you look exactly the same as
you did when you are a teenager like
it's unreal and also your memory here
healthier shinier hair back then for
sure
yeah right can we talk about your mother
who is seemingly the sweetest woman oh
she's a [ __ ] behind literally an angel
walking the earth I'm like she want
everyone to be your mom because great
she is so so sweet and she's been you've
given her makeovers and video and she's
so nice to let me do that yeah how was
she when you're like can you will you
sit down in front of a camp oh she was
great I mean she's literally I've been
making her do makeover with me since I
was 12
like in my house mom let me give you a
makeover it should be so nice like I
tease her hair up and I do all the
makeup and we probably have like one
documented photo of that cuz I got it
sure before from when you were doing the
dishes and now makeover with her does
she understand YouTube at all oh yeah
now she does okay at first you know my
family was like what are you wasting
your time doing little videos
yeah I'm YouTube like you should be
working more to pay myself oh no guys
okay you don't get it it's gonna get big
maybe did she get recognized ever it's
so weird cause she'll get recognized
before me like I'm literally right there
I'm right there next to her I'd be like
oh my gosh you're candy Johnson smile on
my right here and then my mom she was
like so excited she loves when people
come up to red Disney man oh she won't
have to pee cuz I was doing this stupid
detox diet just drinking downsell water
Disney man terrible like I'm in the
bathrooms like the 85th time and my
mom's like oh honey this girl came up
and she said she would just die and cry
if she ever met you in real life and I
said she's actually here she is in the
bathroom I'm on a ride
she can be making other things though
been more like I was like oh that's so
great and then so we're walking out my
mom's like and so we did and she did
start crying and that's amazing as my
mom before me I'm like okay but your
mom's she's a star she's such a sweet
one she is and she'll talk she's like
she'll talk to everybody she's making
friends with everybody
I made friends with this minute the
grocery store my friends and like
everybody's fighting people didn't want
to be your friend oh that's so sweet
also um you're back on a fitness kick
right now yeah yeah for my birthday yeah
how's that go use in July yeah so I have
like a little less than three months of
my math is sort of correct okay what's
the plan
the plan is to be in the best shape of
my life on my birthday oh yeah like we
want like a six-pack and stuff
oh girl you want less yellow light Oh
like where last year at your make up
lunch you're wearing like a latex
full-body thing and I was suffocating on
behalf of sweat out like sweat literally
crawling up at the wrists and I would
like pull the latex thing off and sweat
would come out the most people would hug
me and like the air would poop up the
shoulder and then that stupid dress oh
it was incredible you look like a
cartoon character like disgust like I
felt like literal swine well you held it
well you look very wise 20 pounds stress
I mean they know water weight put trash
bags over and go for a jog like rock you
know get a fool a dress just came out
for the night go on a date but what are
you doing no you're doing just full like
as a trainer
oh hell yeah and she's like a fitness
competitor so I was like just make me
look like you like your body I just want
to buy your body really and then the
first day we did legs like I've been
working out for like a year but like oh
my I couldn't walk for three days really
I couldn't even get out of my car it
took me like a good 45 seconds just to
like move out of the car and then walk
like I'm 90 in the store
oh this is and this is right your mood
is your problem and I was like she's
like what did you eat of it
oh no she's holding you accountable you
can't eat those on my okay so you want
to be in the best shape of your life by
your birthday yeah what does that mean
just like you want to be feeling
physically feeling really strong and fit
I don't want to feel I just want to feel
like I I did this I worked hard enough
to get my body look how I want it to
look yeah and feel strong and feel fit
and feel good and energetic and no but
that's great so you're um you're on
track yeah and I'm gonna order my little
food delivery so I eat the food and now
you have it laughs when you hit your
birthday do you have your like reward
meal or something in mind
or is it like birthday is the goal but
gonna keep going up no I want to keep
going cuz I was in really good shape
before and then then it just changes
your relationship with food and EDM you
get into the not Mexican wedding cookies
yeah and then oh it'll be like bounce
I'll be like oh I can eat the cookies
there you go yeah I used to bake donut
like not donuts I used to bake these
cupcakes eventually did a recipe for
those on YouTube as well I would run
like ten miles a day Wow
I would eat the whole dozen cupcakes
every day I was baking these cupcakes
every day I'm like dude I'm the cupcake
master put me on Cupcake Wars cuz my
recipe will kill and I was like just
eating and it's but it's cancelling out
all the exercise that you're doing yeah
the kids be like didn't you make
cupcakes I was like yeah make another
batch I'll bake five more badges oh I
can't wait to see how the journey
continues thank you well okay we're
gonna take one last quick break and when
we get back with a bunch of Twitter
questions
are you so we were a penguin candy
Johnson another tape this episode of not
too deep is brought to you by Lisa Lisa
believes that Abed is more than just a
place to sleep it's a place for
relaxation and rest and they believe
that every body has the right to rest
and that's why they make two awsome
mattresses plus accessories and bases to
give your body the deep rest it needs
the all foam Lisa mattress is new and
improved featuring cooling LS a 200 foam
for enhanced pressure relief for side
sleepers I don't fully know what that
means but it sounds impressive no
they're superior hybrid mattress is the
perfect combination of foam and spring
for pressure relief and edge to edge
support and Lisa's mission is to provide
a better night's sleep for everybody
from day one so they set out to create a
company with heart and that's why they
donate one mattress for every 10 they
sell to organizations that work in
causes like foster care prevention and
to date they've donated more than 30 mm
mattresses through more than 1,000
nonprofits I have a Lisa mattress I
recently got my mom and stepped out of
Lisa mattress and my mom did her
research and text adventures like I love
that I'm sleeping on a mattress that
gives back to humanity so it's just all
around a really wonderful company and
now you guys can get 15% off your entire
order at Lisa comm slash grace if you
use promo code grace that's l ee s a.com
slash grace promo code grace for years
have been told that quote clean meant
one thing sanitize it's supposed to be
healthy but sanitizers and disinfectants
wipe out everything all the good healthy
stuff along with any of the bad so like
your gut your home has a micro biome too
and research is starting to show that
this kilomole approach may be going too
far with negative effects on our health
especially for our kids but now aunt
Fanny's brings probiotics to your home
and your hands with their new
microcosmic line these household
cleaners and hand soaps add good with
probiotic power each has an extract of
beneficial bacteria
plus super effective plant-based
ingredients to be tough on dirt and
gentle on you these formulas are
non-toxic they're cruelty free and they
have 100% essential oil scent so there's
no fake fragrances they're
hypoallergenic and dermatologist tested
too if you have pets or kids that you
are at all concerned about aunt Fanny's
is the way to go Plus aunt Fanny's who
doesn't want to say that out loud or in
their head when they're purchasing
products that are gonna make their life
better it's a win-win all around why
stop at just natural cleaning when you
can do one better with probiotics shop
now at aunt Fanny's dot-com / good and
get 20% off your entire order with
coupon code grace at checkout that's
aunt Fanny's calm / good coupon code
grace okay candy before we get into
these Twitter questions I'm gonna ask
you the two questions I've asked every
single guest on the podcast and you've
already been a guest in the podcast so
you've answered these in the past but
we'll see if you have new and exciting
will save the new answers the first
question is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti act oh
if I'm gonna do a fast answer I would
say Hitler yeah because that's like the
first awful person that pops into my
hair that makes sense we've had a lot of
Hitler's as answers that's not exciting
no no it's it's just true it's like I we
all want to see it happen yeah like
first stop Hitler done okay the other
question I ask every guest is to tell us
your worst pants shedding story or close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so for instance mine
is college jogging front lawn even
though I guarantee I have an updated one
but at some point we'll figure that out
um I mean it wasn't my pants but I would
say maybe childhood closet closet trash
I'll take it perfect
yeah also wait I just saw that you just
took a personality test oh did you take
the myers-briggs personality yes
how'd it go for you cuz I'm obsessed
with that test it was crazy I'm the
adventurer oh really and I was like I
don't know what the other letters were
with it I just never been juror yeah
yeah and I was like oh dang it this is
like really accurate yeah isn't it scary
should I take it again and really lock
in those couple questions I was long but
I jumped to a new what was yours mine is
the mediator what what does that even
mean it's uh I wrote an INFP it's like
but it also the same thing when I first
took the test I was scared at how
accurate yes
about me that I literally sent it to all
of my friends and as I please take this
join me and then they took it and I
found out that there's were scarily
accurate to them too so I trust the
myers-briggs test like to no end it's
weird because you get these weird
questions and some are like hard to
answer but also I've retaken it like
months later just a double check same
it's the same because there's every
every different category gives you like
a percentage of how much you are like
introvert or extrovert it's like you're
60% introverted 40% but still like my
outcome didn't change but the
percentages of each switch around I
don't want to be the adventurer but this
is my I did say that to large parties
but it is also so fascinating because
then there's another website I figured
what it's called yeah but it's another
myers-briggs website where you can see
how different personalities get along
with each other in terms of friendships
and relationships yeah so any
significant other I might please take
this test and then I immediately go into
like the database and I'm like are we
are we compatible yeah exactly
much better than astrology actually like
this is like treated way deeper
individualized oh yeah but I'm so
excited this year they take all the
breakdowns it was like you in a
relationship yeah in a career I was like
oh my gosh yeah frightening we correct I
think I cried the first time I read it
because it was so intensively like
and I mean to be fair I've been told to
like calm down about it because it's
literally you're filling out a quiz with
all the things about you and the quiz is
just reciting the things you've filled
out back at you basically not really but
more imperative is like all the things
about like do you like social ones do I
was like yeah no not really I don't
yeah and then like the other things I
was like I don't know if I'm answering
right and then my son was reading listen
he's like don't do the middle gray you
have to pick one I was like oh shoot I
was gonna pray I need time I've asked
someone to take it I'm like I won't be
in the room just please be as honest as
possible on this test because the first
time I was filling it out I was a little
I could tell that I was being nervous of
like you know something like a good
answer I know I don't like social
situations but maybe sometimes I I don't
like being home alone all the time like
I kind of like going
I like being invited option knowing I
could know I was so excited cuz I'm like
obsessive about those things and I think
what my letters are seems like I me and
PS J you know what yeah I really the
name my constant mine's a mediator and
that's the only thing I remember great
grace by the way that sounds like you
are wanted everywhere like the mediator
I'm gonna make sure everyone's happy and
everyone's doing okay yeah that's a
great person to have around hey I'll
take it even though the person doesn't
want to leave our house I'll Skype in
yeah okay let's get into these Twitter
questions okay beautiful souls have
beautiful questions for you yay someone
snow hasn't been difficult to remain
such a positive light online throughout
the years the Internet can be a pretty
great place but it can also be super
shitty yeah I mean you are truly like a
self-help book constantly online I feel
like you are always either enforcing on
your Instagram story or on Twitter just
like really positive mantras about like
love and light kind of situations I mean
I hope so I hope it doesn't come off as
like cheeseball because I'll see people
I know dude I'm like that just don't
just go back to just posting your
champagne and your shoes
don't try to be that person you know but
um I hope people feel that it's genuine
from my heart like I know the world is
hurting like I
didn't know the level of people hurting
as much until I started doing YouTube I
didn't know how many people were
suicidal until I started getting all the
emails and I get messages every day of
people like suicide on the verge of
suicide so it just is so huge it's just
huge epidemic and I know I mean not that
everybody's suicidal but everybody feels
down that they don't want to go on
anymore they don't want to deal with the
pain in life so I hope something I say
helps people and even if my agent or
whoever is being like Kandi's stop with
those pose this is not how you're gonna
grow your following you know you're like
it's more than that I'm like but that's
but you don't understand that this
twelve-year-old girl said that she was
thinking of killing herself and I said
something that changed her mind like I
can't even fathom that I could even do
that with this you know so the internet
it's just like trash a lot of the time
so I hope there's something good I get
depressed I go on Twitter to sex on my
wall great it's always such a bright
little moment in my Instagram stories
when it pops up and you're just like
genuinely like I hope that you are happy
and like here's reason to be happy and
I'm like she's right I just hug someone
near me right now hope so cuz I could
those two they're like oh you and your
post I'm like I don't oh you're just so
somebody's like I'm so sick of your
positive post like what you're just so
positive you can't do any more
positivity you're positive now only
imagine your life yeah that person's
really thriving then if they're like I
can't take how happy you want others to
be almost no is the YouTube beauty guru
drama manufactured or real oh it's real
all right
really yeah terribly real I haven't no I
don't deep dive enough to know specifics
of things but I have known that in the
over the last couple years it's become
more like broccoli yeah I feel like I
feel like I'm a little far removed from
it yeah like I'm older and wiser yeah
it's just older but it's I feel like the
people that are more emotionally charged
and feeling some kind of way I feel like
there's just so much drama
like I just are going to some beauty
events cuz I'm like I don't wanna you
don't am I die from her and I if I talk
to you you're mad and think I'm on this
side it's just like middle of high
school yeah yeah like it's even
regressed like it's like middle school
II like really they're just like cheers
yeah invite me to beautycon okay someone
says how does she stay so genuine in the
world of beauty Burres Oh beauty bird
that's a cool I never heard that I'm AB
youtuber I'm just not YouTube no I think
you do a good job of like from the
outside looking in it looks like you do
a good job of like in being in the world
in that realm but also having like the
healthy perspective of like I'm not
getting involved in this drama no and my
own thing totally and it's like a not a
superficial world but I feel like Beauty
can be very much about external yeah
what I mean everything from the car you
drive the bag you wear the shoes you
have how your hair is done what how your
body looks right now it's is become so
different than when it first started you
know mm-hmm um and I feel like for me I
mean maybe it helped like my mom
homeschooled me when I was little so
lately nobody teased me until I went to
like older kids and I went back to
school and I was like look at your
outfit you don't like my shoes then look
at your shoes get away you know nothing
what the heck are you doing I like I'm
just being me over here yeah and these
girls like waiting by ashes that's a
cool store when you buy your shoes like
I didn't get it you know so like I've
just always marched to like beat of my
own drum that was a little different and
you know I mean after some moments I
felt pressure I'm like do I
need to buy a bodycon dress and wear
these Louboutin shoes and buy a YSL
clutch and and do all the things and
then I was like ill you can't it felt
gross yeah no you're gonna wear out
whatever you want to wear I think that's
so important to wear your different
earrings that don't go you're gonna wear
these things
I'm gonna wear these shoes I've worn 12
times yeah my bottom and I like them I
really actually like wearing my outfits
and I will never post about them like I
will dress weird I will not take one
photo to post on Instagram and it's
cooler when you have people on street
being like oh you have dope style you
have this or that ma'am
cool your genuine you're interacting
with me for real I'm not gonna post this
on the internet for all these people to
come batching critics and yeah well why
are you wearing that pattern in this
yeah you don't need that validation in
on the internet that's such an adult
mature perspective on all of this cuz I
think especially young kids and like I
bet that you can imagine this in like
your daughter that like you don't want
her growing up in a world where she
feels like numbers validate you know her
likes or I mean that egg got more likes
and Kylie Jenner I mean Korey Kuhl told
me Marie and I that and I was like
you're pranking us that's impossible and
then I was like this is incredible you
have the Internet is arbitrary and
stupid and invalidating and I met the
three people that were behind the egg
and they were like I don't know how many
days he's been replying and coming to
everyone and getting this thing and I
was like okay random like normal thing
this was calculated yeah then it takes a
lot of the mystique away I think about
like some of the coolest musicians the
coolest people you know they don't have
a following like they have very little
following sorry I don't followings
insignificant to me like yeah in the
beauty committee if you want to collab
because you have X amount or the
followers and I'm like that's just gross
right now cuz it's a cool person I'm so
so so with you I also
that you curate your own Instagram to be
whatever the [ __ ] you wanted to be
everything post any gumbo potpourri
massive but I love that because I
sometimes go through like peaks and
valleys of going oh should i curate
something that's a manufactured and
looks a certain way that gives a vibe
and I'm like no my vibe is sloppy floppy
like whatever is happening and so that I
can't I it would be so father something
to try and like go through and see me
like I'm like blue is my theme I'm like
what what I did this yesterday like I
can't fit the scene yeah yeah no I love
that you're just still like here's a
photo great here we go okay someone to
know what have you learned this year
candy is so full of wisdom oh gosh well
thanks I mean I think you are what's the
biggest thing you've learned in like the
last year
oh the last year that would be a really
big lesson what happened last year um I
mean it was a lot of things like
relationship stuff it was I lost like
both my grandparents it was I think in
letting go of things and then realizing
like to take care of me because I don't
do that and like not to be like oh
self-care self-care self-care but when
you have a work ethic which I would say
more than a hustle because I feel like
everybody's saying they hustle nowadays
and like it just sounds cold without
husband killer it's a buzzword yeah like
but the difference is like having a work
ethic is something you don't always talk
about you're just doing it you know like
I don't post it I'm up every night
working I don't haven't posted anything
that people don't know I'm working on
behind the scenes right and you're not
sitting there being like secret project
secret projects you can tell that
sometimes I am because I'm like I
haven't talked about this in like six
months and I should say something but
but I think what I've learned is like
you really have to take time and like
even for me being like take 15 minutes a
day and just sit and don't look at your
phone just let your idea let your brain
process without any stimulus in there
and do things to take care of me so I
feel recharged and I feel healthy
because being on your grind for you know
this decade of YouTube has been the
hardest I've ever worked in my life like
having 25 jobs with no days off mhmmm
and when you've gone record days without
sleeping more than four hours you're you
know you're not eating right you're just
editing it's just not healthy you know
and even having so many people give
their feedback on your life
yeah really hard and so I think you just
have to step back and I think I've just
realized like this is my life and the
things I want to do and sometimes what
looks like something falling apart or
something not working is actually like
like when you prune a rosebush you know
like you have to prune some of it so it
can blossom back more and instead of me
feeling bad about areas some areas are
being pruned off and removed it so that
the blossoms can grow bigger in other
areas I'm not just like beating this
dead thing over here making it work you
know there's something bigger that's
like drop that stupid yeah this thing's
gonna be 20 times bigger yeah I know
doing that I think has been a big lesson
I think that's huge and super important
for people to realize that sometimes you
have to cut wait to like get to the
surface a little you know
and also it's recognizing when to cut
the way is right because you could waste
so much time trying to figure out how to
pull this up with yeah when it's never
go nowhere yeah and the piece isn't
there the joy isn't into something and
there's always gonna be joy into
something new and it's just so crazy how
you see like some people started as one
thing and then they left you know Justin
Bieber still isn't doing drums on
YouTube like the drum master on Justin
Bieber drummer boy you know like it's
like oh how he hasn't done a drummer boy
like Christmas he's like coming back
okay last question someone to know
what's your YouTube guilty pleasure or
just pleasure like is this something
that you go on and you watch or YouTube
guilty pleasure or just like a stress
relief or anything that you're like I'm
gonna turn this on and it's this is
gonna
sounds so weird but there's a lot of
vlogs like family vlogs that my kids
like and some I'm just like no no no no
for various reasons yeah myriad of
reasons why this is not gonna be watched
but the one there's this family I think
they're called the Norris nuts in
Australia okay they're the most charming
adorable family I've ever seen in my
life
and they've got their little Australian
accent which I'm terrible at so I'm not
even gonna bother rotating it like the
brother and sister like one the little
girls like a skater in the X Games the
little brother competes surfing and then
they sing these songs and they're like
they're just like so cute to it I've
never seen siblings queue to each other
norris nuts i think so okay I'm gonna
what the phrases like catch me knuckles
cuz they like catch each other cutest
that's too cute would you just leave so
happy no like I want to be more like
kids the world how the positive like
when one didn't they were both competing
at the X Games and the one she's like I
didn't feel bad for her and they're like
tiny something I just wanted her to win
more than me I didn't want to do my best
and you're just like oh no listen for
everyone in the world like too pure yeah
the pureness is what gets me that's
amazing i watch too much of the garbage
trash I feel terrible my god I've had to
reevaluate a lot of the garbage trash
that I've just been watching as a
distraction to be like maybe this is not
good exactly okay Kenny what are you
working on now can you say anything
about anything gaming I can say some
vague boring things something I've been
working on will be coming out in sold in
stores it's not a makeup product oh cool
but it will be in stores the end of this
year nice we just had to finalize like
final color of the packaging oh my god
and we couldn't totally do the page the
color I wanted but it's still gonna be
great okay I guess you can't read my
idea the holographic letters that were
just gonna come off at your eyes I mean
but that'll be by the end of this year
yeah this year and then
like a couple TV projects sweet I mean I
hope they I hope they keep going and
yeah that's so cool that's great Mike I
don't edit I'll do a TV show show I'll
do a Netflix show I will come and sit in
the park okay Kenny
everyone that's made time for be on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie this is made for you specifically
it's made for me the prank the fortune
lists fortune oh man that would be such
a bleak way to maybe use like who put
this in here oh my gosh happy belated
ten years on YouTube now your bear leg
entire series miss grace you got a girl
this is going on my own this is all
right feels real real aesthetically
pleasing like and this is going Kenny
thank you so much for coming back on the
haka where can people find you if they
don't know online just at candy Johnson
my parents build it ka and de e Johnson
is regular that's all over Instagram
snapchat thank you so much again great
of course we'll see you guys next time
on another episode of not too deep
goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep this
episode of not too deep ism brought to
you by bare minerals as the creators of
clean Beauty bare minerals is driven by
a philosophy that makeup and skincare
should make your skin better not just
better looking and that's why their
best-selling original foundation is made
with only five ingredients and you
guessed it they're all minerals for bare
minerals to be clean without compromise
means good for skin formulas with proven
performance so upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match and first time customers will get
15% off when you use the promo code not
too deep bare minerals the power of good
not too deep as a production of grace
Helbig incorporated producer and edited
by Melissa Dumont's
writing by Diane cash
production assistance by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]